now here's a problem though you will
notice that there's plenty of things in
life plenty of pairs of values and
quantities but don't match this don't
behave like this okay for instance for
those of you who like me live in the
glorious Hills okay we've got places
like you to stop it more and console
tales don't check out charge anything
for your parking right you just sit
there for as long as you're lame but if
you go to I mean first locally i guess
you'd go to Russell town center right
and if you think about how much they
charge for how long you park there right
so charge for parking okay as you
consider how long you just stay there
right so that would be ours part I guess
here's another pair of quantities and
they are related but they're not related
in this way and there's no smooth wine
for instance you can stay there for does
anyone know how long before you have to
pay it's generally three hours isn't it
I think Paris feels like copyright c
they're all the same basically so if I
put some some marks now do you want to
something like this okay for the first
three hours you pay zip right so that's
this that corresponds to 0 down here
zero dollars right so if I were to graph
that it would look like this okay now
that's nice that's that's still linear
right but the second year there for
three hours and one minute what happened
you're gonna pay now I don't know what
is it like I know four dollars five
dollars something there abouts okay so
let's put that number on here let's do
this up in two dollar increments two
dollars four dollars six and so on okay
so for instance suppose you had to pay
yeah let's call it five dollar so i'm
going to be in between here right so at
this point fudge or
the graph chops up right and you keep
paying that five dollars right if you
were there for three hours and one
minute three hours and two minutes you
still pay the same amount within
whatever I don't know there are half
hour chunks or one hour looks something
like that okay then of course if you go
past another threshold right you can see
what's going on you're familiar with
this idea right so something like this
would happen and then you know depending
if you're in this city or something like
that you know you get charged
something's orbit and raised for some
parking sometimes okay so let's think
about this for a second because it's a
fifth thing snows number one would you
describe it as linear limits how you
define linear right I mean in some ways
we call these linear graphs because
literally knowledge sets question it's a
straight line right if you graph this
that's the kind of relationship you have
selenium makes sense is a word to
describe that are this straight lines
you there are straight lines aren't
there straight across here are straight
across user so it is a linear kind of
relationship but as you can see it
doesn't have the same kind of thing here
because of the shape of it we call this
they don't know they don't actually a
step graph or step function because they
literally looks like steps okay and you
have all these intervals here so there's
the first thing to those that it does
cover to the very very broad heading of
linear relationships but it's clearly in
a different class of our relationship
than what we looked at those there's the
first things got a different name okay
the other thing is that there's a
problem with this graph the probably key
that we didn't have over here okay for
instance we said right if you were there
for three hours and one minute you'd be
paying five bucks okay but what do you
pay if you're there for three hours and
exactly three hours
well on the graph that I have drawn you
can't really tell can't you it could be
either you pay nothing or you pay the
next bracket up right now you can't pay
both obviously I guess rasa tahn said it
would might be paid both but we want to
define it as one or the other okay the
reason why this is probably here but not
on an original graph is because this has
what we call discontinued ease these
gaps right discontinuities the technical
name ok it's not always continuous yeah
so therefore we need to have some
rotation on you it shows am I here or
here am I here or here and so on ok so
the way this tends to be done is raise
little circles so for instance after a
circle like that so it's filled
indicating ok add that end of the
boundary well we're excited at little
service today that in the very that's
why we could do but here at three hours
on the dime you don't get off free
actually as soon as it takes seven to
three hours you're paying money ok so
this indicates it sort of sorts out the
ambiguity am I here on here well now you
can tell the difference and I guess we
would follow the pattern all the way up
ok so in other words it means at these
points where it's not clear which one
right you take this value not this one
okay then go right and it's playing
other relationships that fit this kind
of step graph idea